Transcriber: Can Boysan
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
On adımda on iki adım.
Yani daha yaratıcı olmak mümkün şeklinde.
Burası Afrika, Moritanya sahili.
Arkada yerli bir kabile var,
son derece tehlikeliler,
lütfen denemeyiniz dedim.
Öyle bir şey yok tabii,
bildiğiniz Antalya,
arkadakiler de animasyoncu arkadaşlar.
Sadece, sadece şunu yapmaya çalışıyorum.
Instagram'dan beni takip eden varsa,
garip garip foto manipülasyonlarım var.
Böyle mekan kaymaları
falan gerçekleştirerek
arkadaki nesnelerle oynayarak
farklı fotoğraflar
bir şekilde tasarlıyorum.
Bunu yapmak çok önemli değil
ama kafanın bu şekilde çalışması önemli.
Yaratıcılığın sürdürülebilir olması
anlamında, biraz ondan bahsedeceğim.
Şimdi, bu slayt önemli,
slayttakiler de çok önemli.
Gördüğünüz gibi,
Salvador Dali'den tutun, Picasso'ya,
Edgar Allan Poe'ya, Atatürk,
Steve Jobs, Tesla,
Madam Curie, Virginia Woolf var.
Tabii her biri büyük deha.
Aslında olmamaları,
dünya tarihindeki mozaikte
bir kayma meydana getirir herhalde,
bir eksiklik meydana getirir.
Hepimizin aklına geliyor
değil mi soru işaretleri,
bu insanların bizlerden
farklı olan özelliği ne acaba?
Yani deha diyoruz da,
sahip oldukları şey yaratıcılık mı?
Yaratıcılıksa, bunun sayesinde
gerçekleştirmişlerse
acaba bizden genetik olarak farklılar mı?
Farklı aile öyküleri var mı?
Ya da farklı bir üslup mu kullanıyorlar?
Potansiyellerini nasıl
harekete geçirmişler?
Temelde hepimizin aklına gelen sorular.
Bugüne kadar bilim dünyasının bu alanda
geldiği yeri ben size kabaca özetleyeyim.
Büyük ihtimalle bizlerden
çok çok büyük farklılıkları yok.
Ama tutumlarında büyük farklılıklar var.
Zaten ben de biraz ondan söz edeceğim.
Yani bu yaratıcılık dediğimiz şey,
biz işte bu salondaki herkes
mütevazı ve sıradan insanlar
olduğumuzu düşünelim.
Acaba bu yaratıcılıkta bir şekilde
sıçrama gerçekleştirebilir miyiz?
Tamam deha olmayalım
ama en azından yaratıcılığımızı
maksimize edebilir miyiz,
biraz bunlardan söz edeceğim.
Bu önemli, gelecekçilik hakkında
pek çok okuyorsunuz, dinliyorsunuz.
İşte fütürizm meselesi.
Bir kere yaratıcılığın önemi
buradan kaynaklanıyor.
Eğer gelecek, bizim bu ütopik dediğimiz
hani, muhteşem bir seyirde gelecekse
bunun adı entelektüel kapitalizm olacak
ve bunun temelinde yaratıcılık olacak,
yani bu mükemmel kapitalizmde
yaratıcı olmayan bireylerin
ve yaratıcı olmayan ülkelerin
ayakta kalabilmesinin
çok imkânı görünmüyor arkadaşlar.
Bakın, bizim geleceği tasavvur ederken
çok insanın böyle doğasına,
projeleme sistemine de çok uygun bir şey.
İptidai bir hatamız vardır.
Biz geleceğin yekpare bir gelecek
olarak geleceğini düşünüyoruz.
İşte yapay zekalar,
sensör teknolojileri, vesaire.
İşte robotikler, algoritmalar.
Gelecek yekpare gelmeyecek,
bugün de öyle değil ki.
2019'un Afganistan'ıyla
Kanada'sı aynı mı?
2050'nin Türkiye'siyle İngiltere'si
niye aynı olsun?
Bir şekilde yeteri kadar
çağın gerekliliklerine,
yetenek ve becerilerine
uygun yaratıcı bireyler
ve dolayısıyla kolektif
bir kültür geliştirebileceğimiz,
geliştirebildiğimiz durumda
hayatta kalacağız.
Tam söz bu, "survival" hayatta kalmak.
O yüzden yaratıcılık
çok çok önemli bir kavram.
Çok net söyleyeyim size, adı bu olur olmaz
ama gelecek iyi gelecekse kesinlikle
hayal gücü iktidara gelecek.
Başka bir şans görünmüyor.
Peki buradan hareketle,
yaratıcılık, hayal gücü, inovasyon
dediğimiz zaman beyinden söz ediyoruz.
Biraz, çok kısaca beynin durumuna bakalım.
Durum bu kadar ciddi olmayabilir
ama bu arkadaş,
her birimizde birer tane var.
Gerçekten zorlanıyor yani, onu söyleyeyim.
Bakın bugün ortalama bir insanın zihninden
yaklaşık 70 bin düşünce
geçtiğini söylüyoruz.
Batı odaklı bir kapitalizmde yaklaşık
3 bin reklam mesajına maruz kalıyoruz.
Bugün CIA'in 1960 yılında
bir ayda ulaşabildiği bilgiye
Ankara'da yaşayan 12 yaşındaki bir çocuk
sadece bir günde ulaşabiliyor
ve bununla beynin başa çıkması
çok zor çünkü hep şunu söylüyoruz,
insanın kültürel evrimi, insanın biyolojik
evriminin çok çok öncesinde gidiyor.
Yani 2.5 milyon yılda
konuşma edimini kazanan insan
yaklaşık 300 yıl önceki
bilgi birikimine dayanarak
işte bugün hiper reel kentler inşa ediyor.
İşte yapay zekalarla,
algoritmalarla çalışıyor.
Bir de zaten muhteşem bir kapasitesi var.
2.5 milyon gigabayt
veriyi toplayabildiğini,
biriktirebildiğini söylüyoruz beynin.
Bu ne demek biliyor musunuz?
2.5 petabayt, işte hadron
patlamasını falan yaparsınız.
Yani orada çıkan veri,
yaklaşık böyle bir veri.
Bugün kaydetmeye başlasanız
300 yıl boyunca her birimizin
o kafatasının içerisindeki eşsiz donanım,
sürekli, hiç kesintisiz HD bir filmi,
bir televizyon yayınını,
bir diziyi kaydedebilir.
Düşünsenize, 300 yıl yaklaşık,
"Erkenci Kuş"u kaydettiğini.
(Kahkahalar)
Zaten mesele de biraz orada başlıyor.
Yani, yaratıcının önemli
bir adımıdır, seçilim kriteri.
Mesele orada başlıyor.
Beyin isyan ederken
acaba hani onu bir şekilde nasıl
doğru kullanabiliriz meselesinde.
İşte ben formulü,
gördüğünüz gibi oluşturdum.
Denklem biraz karışık duruyor.
Tabii ki denklem bu değil,
bir görsel databanktan aldım
ama ben madde madde sıralayacağım size.
Birincisi idrak yöntemi,
adını ben böyle koydum.
Dünya gerçekten bence
idrak yolları enfeksiyonu
diye adlandırabileceğimiz
bir durum yaşıyor.
Çok sevdim bunu, bulurken bu lafı.
Kimse birbirini anlayamıyor,
yani, anne kızını anlayamıyor,
baba oğlunu anlayamıyor.
Beyaz siyahı anlamıyor,
devlet vatandaşını anlamıyor.
Yazar, aydın, okuyucusunu anlayamıyor.
Bayağı bir idrak problemi var.
Oysaki insan beyninin
en büyük fonksiyonlarından,
en üst fonksiyonlarından biridir idrak.
Yani derin anlama, yani kavrayabilme,
yani dünyayı okuyabilme.
Yani kavuşma, kesişme.
Biz, idrak yeteneğimiz bizde,
hepimizde var
ama biz onu kullanmadığımız zaman
beynin kendisi zaten bir kas olduğu için
kullanılmamış vaziyette orada duruyor
ve ilginç bir şekilde
siz kullanmadığınızda
cevabını bir şekilde size veriyor.
Peki nasıl kullanabilirsiniz
idrak meselesini?
Evet kitap okumak,
başka kültürleri görmek,
bunun üzerine muhalif olabilmek,
kendine bile muhalif olabilmek.
Muhakeme yeteneğini geliştirmek,
hayatındaki her şeyi bir anlam yolculuğu
içerisinde değerlendirebilmek.
Yaradılışın kaynağını anlamak.
Bunlar idrak fonksiyonunu
geliştiren meseleler
ve bir şekilde sürdürülebilir olarak da
bunun devam ettiğini düşünmemiz lazım.
Yani sizin, hepimizin
verili bir özelliği haline geliyor
ama biz onu kullanmak istediğimiz zaman.
Bakın, Rodin'in heykeli.
Bu sadece bireyde de kalmıyor aslında,
kolektif bir kültür haline geliyor.
Üstteki de 3800 yıl önceden,
yani Orta Bronz Çağ'dan kalmış bir heykel.
İlginç bir şekilde, ikisinin de,
iki heykelin adı da şair.
Biz Düşünen Adam diye biliyoruz
ama çünkü şairler düşünce satan adamlar
ve aslında insanlık o binlerce
yılda çok da değişmemiş.
Kolektif kültüre bunu bağlarsak
160 kadar ülkede Rodin'in heykeli
olduğu söyleniyor.
Hemen hemen tüm ülkelerde üniversitelerde,
müzelerde, kütüphanelerin önünde
ama biz akıl hastanelerinin
önünde kullanıyoruz bunu.
Bu işte kolektif kültüre idrakın
nasıl yansıdığına ilişkin bir unsur.
Çünkü işte bunun devamı
"icat çıkarma" oluyor.
Böyle şeyler bizim düşünce dünyamızın,
dil dünyamızın bir parçası olduğunda da
icat çıkarmıyoruz açıkçası.
İkinci mesele uzman nöronlar oluşturmak.
Yaratıcılık dediğimiz olgu aslında
basit nörobiyolojik bir faaliyet.
Şöyle gerçekleşiyor,
işte 80 ile 100 milyar arasında
nöronumuz var değil mi, zihnimizde.
Bunların 15 milyar kadarı
bizim duygulanım, öğrenme, yaratıcılık
dediğimiz faaliyetlerle ilgileniyor.
Biz onları kullanmaya başladığımızda,
figüratif bir şey anlatıyorum.
Kabaca herhangi bir alanda;
enstrüman çalmak, spor, müzik,
yaratıcılık, yazarlık vesaire,
aklınıza ne geliyorsa.
O hücrelerden bir kısmının
sola doğru çekildiğini düşünün.
Onun üzerinde kilometre
yapmaya başladığınızda
o hücrenin öbekleştiğini düşünün
ve uzman hücreler
haline geldiğini düşünün.
Bakın, 1995'ten beri reklamcıyım,
hep yaratıcı endüstrinin
içerisinde bulundum.
Edebiyat eleştirileri yazdım,
projeler geliştirdim.
2008'de ilk kitabımı yazdım,
iki buçuk yıl kadar sürdü.
Geçen ay on beşinci kitabımı yazdım
ve bence ilk kitabımdan
daha iyi bir kitap oldu,
daha kabul edilebilir bir kitap oldu.
Ayda beş tane dergiye yazı çıkarıyorum.
Bunlar Harvard, Bloomberg,
Milliyet ve BrandMap, TR!P.
Benim beynimde bu uzman nöron
geliştirme aracılığıyla diyeyim
bir kod çözüldü,
neye ilişkin bir kod çözüldü?
Yazmaya ilişkin bir kod çözüldü.
Dolayısıyla bizim aslında
yetenek dediğimiz şey,
tanımı nereden baksan değişir
ama basitçe var olan bir duyusal
kapasitenin mükemmelleştirilmiş hali.
Dolayısıyla öğrenme pratiğinde
bu uzman nöronlar geliştirme pratiğine
mutlaka dikkat etmemiz gerekiyor.
Bir üçüncü mesele
odaklanmış mod,
dağınık mod yöntemi.
Bu, karar veriminde ve aynı zamanda
yaratıcılık ve öğrenmede
çok önemli iki kavram.
Sol beyin, sağ beyin meselesine
çok fazla yer ayırdık.
Biraz da klişe haline geldi.
Literatür onu dışlamaya çalışıyor
son yıllardaki araştırmalarla
ama bu önemli.
Beynin iki modu olduğunu
söylüyoruz yaratıcılık esnasında.
Bir tanesi dağınık mod,
şu an dağınık modu kullandığımı düşünün.
Sahnedeyim, ışıklar var, siz varsınız.
Servet Hocamı görüyordum burada,
işte Gökçen'i görüyorum.
Şu an dünyayı algılamaya çalışıyorum.
Yani büyük resmi görüyorum,
bu dağınık mod.
Bir de bunun odaklanmış modu var.
Odaklanmış mod ise sadece Gökçen'in
o güzel ceketiyle ilgilenmek, mesela.
Bunu yaratıcılıkta nasıl kullanırız,
size ifade edeyim.
Kendi kullandığım da bir yöntem
ama sadece ben kullanmıyorum.
Bunu Salvador Dali'den Picasso'ya,
hatta Osmanlı'da hakimlerin
o kalem yöntemi dediği şey.
Bakın, kendinize boş,
izole bir ortam bulun.
O izole ortamda, mesela ben
reklamcılıkta bunu yapardım.
Reklam öncesinde hedef kitle,
analiz, strateji, hepsine bakacağız.
O analizi yapın kafanızda,
beyinde yaklaşık
bir saatlik öğrenme süreci
mükemmel bir toparlama
gerçekleştiriyor, böyle düşünün.
Bir koltukta oturun, o koltuk --
benim uğurlu bir anahtarlığım vardı,
Beşiktaş anahtarlığı --
düşünerek o yöntemle, o pratikle
ne çalışıyorsanız
yavaş yavaş uykuya dalın,
tütsü falan da iyi gider bu arada,
koku yani duyuyu harekete geçirmek için.
Bir zaman sonra uykuya geçtiğinizde
kaslarınız o elinizdeki
anahtarlığı tutamayacağı için
pat diye düşecek ve o noktadan sonra
dağınık moddan, aslında
odaklanmış moda geçeceksiniz.
Topladığınız mükemmelleştirilmiş bilgi
o konu hakkında bir anda odaklanmış modda
sizin çok hızlıca o projeyi
çıkarmanıza neden olacak.
Muhteşem proje, azımsamayın,
mutlaka bunu deneyin.
Bir başka mesele,
tersine mühendislik yöntemi.
Çok eğlenceli, Tyler Lannister ile
Jon Snow'un hayvan pazarlığı yapması
ya da Lord of The Rings'de
Cüneyt Arkın ile Ediz Hun'un olması
ama kafa bu şekilde
çalıştığı sürece iş görüyor.
En çok izlediğiniz dizileri alın
tersine mühendislikle
veya cümleleri ögesine
ayırmak gibi düşünün.
Defalarca izleyebilirsiniz aynısını
veya başka başka
dizileri izleyebilirsiniz.
Karakterleri yazın, tanımlamaya çalışın,
olay örgüsünü tanımlayın.
Her şeyi tanımlayın
-- kamera, en sevdiğiniz sözleri --
büyük bir defteriniz olsun.
Bunu çeşitli prodüksiyonlarla
tekrar tekrar yapın.
Bir zaman sonra da hatırlamak için
bunları tekrar okuyun.
Göreceksiniz, intihali olmayan bir
yöntemle belli bir süre geçtikten sonra
bu muhteşem yaratıcılıklar sizin olacak.
Çünkü beynin örüntüsel
öğrenme yöntemi buna dayanıyor.
Bakın çok basit yöntemler bunlar
ama inanılmaz etkili
olduğunu göreceksiniz.
Bir başka mesela iş birlikçi olmak.
Jim Rohn önemli bir Amerika'da
kişisel gelişim yazarı,
çok zeki bir adamdır.
Diyor ki: "Dünyanın en zeki
insanı da olsanız
bulunduğunuz ortam
vasat ve vasatın altındaki
kimselerden ibaret ise,
düzeyinizi bile koruma imkânınız yoktur."
Altı üstü beş kişiden ibaretsiniz.
Etrafınızda değerli insanlar olsun.
Farklı farklı sektörlerden, ben bunu
yaparak senaryo yazmaya başladım.
Gökçen benim arkadaşım olduğu için
ondan çok şey öğreniyorum.
Etrafınıza değerli insanlar toplayın,
bu değerli insanlar,
-- çünkü insanın en üst
fonksiyonlarından biri sosyalleşmedir --
size bu iş birliği anlamında
muhteşem yetiler kazandıracaktır.
Bir de artısı, mutlaka
insan detoksunu yapın.
Enerjinizi çalmak isteyen
enerji vampirleri
çünkü herkes geleceğe
sizin gibi bakmayabilir,
hayatınızdan uzaklaştırın.
Neticede uzmanlaşma her şey.
Profesyonel değilim ama ben
kendi dalımın her şeyinde uzmanım
ve benim önüme ne çıkarırsanız
çıkarın uzmanım.
Dünya mutfağında da uzmanım
çünkü ben gördüm bir tekniği, öğrendim,
her şeyde ben uzmanım
ve her zaman da en iyi uzman ben olacağım.
Üçüncü eşeğe dikkat.
Çok acayip bir şey yapıyor, ben dedim ki,
dünyayı uyumsuzlar kurtaracak.
Uyumsuz, pes etmeyen,
olanı olduğu gibi kabul etmeyen
ve hep yeni peşinde koşan beyindir.
Duruma bakıyor, bir çözüm
geliştirmeye çalışıyor.
Onun üzerinden atlamak mantıklı gelmiyor.
Bakın alıyor, belki izleyeniniz
vardır bu videoyu.
Bence çok çarpıcı.
Şu an bu bir insan beyni olsa
ve çözüm üretmeye çalışsa
beyninde yüz fonksiyon anlamında
muhteşem şeyler gerçekleşecek,
yeni bağlantılar kurulacak.
Mutlaka uyumsuz olmak gerekiyor.
Bir başka prensip, Kazım Bey'in gücü.
Bunun konuyla ilgisi yok,
Kazım Abi bizim mahallede
peynirci aslında.
Kıyak olsun diye koydum oraya
çünkü yıllardır bana,
"Hocam televizyonlarda dolaşıyorsun,
bir bizi ünlü yapmadın, biz Burhan Çeçen
gibi dolaşıyoruz" diyor.
Yani, neden geldin İstanbul'a diye,
gerçekten sadece ondan koydum.
İnsanları sevin, onlara iyi davranın.
Bakın Kazım Abi için bir ilk gerçekleşti,
çok sevinecek videoyu gördüğünde.
Kadın, erkek beyni.
Bu slayt her şeyi bitiriyor.
Sadece okuyun.
Testisleri koruyucu tampon
ilk defa 1874 yılında kullanıldı.
Kafayı koruyan kask ise
ilk defa 1974'te kullanıldı.
Anlamamız yaklaşık 100 yıl sürdü
şu beta alfa versiyonunu.
Bence çok güzel, ampirik de
olsa güzel bir veri.
Bir başka mesele -- bu videonun
tümünü gösteremeyeceğim,
çok uzun ama muhteşem bir kaos var burada.
Kaos, yaratıcılığın ilk adımıdır,
ilk önce her şeyi toplayın,
topladığınız şeyleri sonra ayrıştırın,
bölün, çalıştırın, tekrardan
dolaşıma sokun.
Bu kavgada başlangıçta birbirini döven
şu soldaki iki tane arkadaş,
kavganın sonunda herkesi dövmeye başlıyor.
Resmen kaostan iş birliği doğuyor.
Sosyalleşme dedim.
Kaos önemli, kaosa değer verin.
Bir başkası, sıfırlama yöntemi,
bu da çok önemli.
İnsan beyninin en çabuk çalıştığı
durum ne biliyor musunuz?
Beyin görüntülemelerinde cayır cayır
yandığını görüyorsunuz.
Boş duvara bakın beş dakika.
Ardından bildiğiniz yarı hipnoz gibi olun
ve hayal gücüne dalın.
Beynin işte çeşitli
nöro görüntüleme cihazlarında
cayır cayır yandığını göreceksiniz,
bundan daha iyisi yok.
Yöntem bu mu bilmiyorum,
bunu da tercih edebilirsiniz.
Meditasyon da iyi gelebilir,
yoga da iyi gelebilir.
Sakın küçümsemeyin,
ben buna sıfırlama yöntemi dedim.
Bu arada bakın burada bile
özellikli durumlar göreceksiniz.
Şu sağa doğru ilerleyen
arkadaşa bakın, amcaya.
Yeni bir şey yapıyor karşılıklı,
diğerleri hep aynısını yaparken.
Özgün olmak -- bunu da
ileride söyleyeceğim --
Boş zaman tekniği, niye bize diyorlar ki
hobiler geliştirin, stresten uzak kalın.
Kendi potansiyelinizi zorlayın.
Bence çok önemli Vedat Abi, yani.
Garip gelebilir buradan
bakıldığında böyle
ama ben gerçekten çok
ilham verici buldum kendisini.
Boş zaman etkinlikleri önemli,
kortikal stresten uzak durur,
sizin yaratıcı gücünüz olur.
Bir başka mesele, risk almalısınız.
Dünyada risk almayan bir yaratıcı yok.
Barış Manço'dan Zeki Müren'e,
ne bileyim John Lennon'dan
aklıınıza gelebilecek Dali'ye kadar
bütün herkes risk alarak bir yere geldi.
Çorum'da bir karayolu.
Son akşam yemeği,
İsa'nın son yemeği gibi oluyor
ama ben, çok önemli buldum bunu.
Risk almak lazım.
Bir başka mesele, zekanın her türünü
kullanmamız gerekiyor yaratıcılık için,
fiziksel, duygusal, zihinsel zekayı
kullanmamız gerekiyor.
Bakın, diğerleri dolanıyor
şirin bebeklerden.
Sağdakine dikkat edin.
Google'ın 25 yıl sonra
-- eğer Google varsa --
CEO'su olacak.
Çünkü fiziksel kapasiteni de
kullanmak zorundasın.
Bir başka mesele, en sorulmayacak
soruları sormanız lazım.
İlk önce kendinize.
En sorulmayacak sorunun
nasıl soru olduğunu
Nihat Hoca'nın yüzünden anlayacaksınız.
Bu soruları kendinize
dahi sorabildiğinizde --
"Benim kaşlarım kalındı,
şekil verdim, bu sizce caiz midir?"
Bu bakış.
Birine bu soruyu sorabiliyorsanız
doğru yolda ilerliyorsunuz,
onu söyleyeyim size.
Keşke videoların hepsini izleyebilsek
muhteşem videolar.
Bir başkası, özgün olmak.
Bakın, dilencileri sadece çeşitli
engelleri taklit ederken görüyorsunuz.
Görme, yürüme, koltuk değnekleri
ama eğer bu adam bacaklarını
-- sağda bakın kendisi var --
böyle yapıyorsa bırakın,
salıverin gitsin, bu sanattır.
O parayı hak etmiştir.
Özgün olmak lazım.
Bir başkası, tutarlı olmak lazım.
Yaratıcılık insanın hayatının bir parçası.
Yozgat boşuna Yozgat olmadı.
Gerçekten tutarlılık.
Bir başkası, fırsatları görmek zorundasın.
Burada yaklaşık 2 bin kişi var.
Her biriniz gelişmeye çok açık,
muhteşem insanlarsınız.
Benim kitabım da öyle bir kitap,
sizi nereden bulacağım başka türlü,
ben bunu yazdım.
20 liraya bu yöntemlerin hepsini
indirimli olarak alabilirsiniz.
Ayrıca, Instagram'dan
etkileşim sağlamak lazım.
Şu an itibariyle beni takip eden
ilk beş kişiye imzalı gönderiyorum.
Ama YouTube'daki etkileşimi de
sağlamak zorundayım.
YouTube yayına girdiğinde de
en güzel yorumu yapan beş kişiye
imzalı gönderiyorum, yapacağım bunu.
Buradan da etkileşim.
Hayat fırsatları görmektir.
Şans geldiğinde kullanmaktır.
Ama en önemlisi sonuncusu.
Amerikan Psikoloji Derneği
diyor ki son bülteninde
yaratıcılığı geliştiren şey
tutku, ilham ve aşktır.
Bunlarsız yaratıcılık diye bir şey olmaz.
Eğer işinize, hayatınıza karşı
bu motivasyonu sağlayamıyorsanız
sizi motive edecek bir şey bulun.
Ben doğduğumdan beri hayatımdaki her şeyi,
altı yaşındaki
-- şu an altı yaşında olan --
kızım için yapıyorum.
Onun gurur duyabileceği
bir baba olmaya çalışıyorum.
Bu benim için çok çok önemli.
Bir öğrenme zorluğu yaşıyordu,
çözdük çok şükür.
Geçen hafta sınıfında şunu söylemiş,
-- öğretmeni bunu yapabilir misin
diye sorduğunda --
"Benim babam Uğur Batı" demiş,
"tabii ki yaparım" demiş.
Bu benim aslında kariyer zirvem.
Bundan daha iyi bir söz duymadım,
muhtemelen de duymayacağım.
O yüzden kendisine her doğum
gününde bir şarkı yazıyorum.
Yedi yaşından itibaren de
birer hikâye kitabı yazacağım.
Bu ilk doğum günü için bestelediğim şarkı,
Cenk'le birlikte söyledik
-- Cenk Yüksel'le -- sevgili arkadaşım.
Sizi onunla baş başa bırakıyorum
ve seviliyorsunuz,
çok teşekkür ediyorum.
(Alkış)
"Açıldı, yandı, yandı anlatıldı.
Aklım almadı ama kalbime sığdı.
O benim hayatım oldu, ben de onun ruhu.
Düşler kızı Elvin.
Hoş geldin Elvin."